- [Kelly] I mean, you're bringing
a little country with that dress,
(Julia chuckles)
I like it, I like it.
- Thank you.
- Have y'all met before?
- No.
- It's so lovely to meet you.
- Oh, great to meet
you, I liked your show.
- Thank you.
(Kelly laughs)
I liked your shows too.
(Julia laughs)
- Thanks, thanks.
- [Kelly] I think a few have watched, Lisa
- A few, just a few.
(Kelly laughs)
- So, do your kids express
interest in learning about,
you know, the Orthodox Jews,
do they express anything?
- Well, they all lived in
that community with me.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Right, my daughter was
already married when I left.
So, they know enough.
- [Kelly] So, have they talked
about it at all, though?
Like the switch.
- [Julia] You know, to them...
- [Kelly] I guess why
I'm saying this is like,
even with like, divorce with my family,
like my kids, I feel like
we've talked about it enough
and then it'll just come back up again.
And I'm like, "Oh, we're revisiting it".
(audience laughs)
So, yeah.
- I think they're just very grateful
for the life that we have now.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And that they get to
make their own choices
and that their biology
doesn't define their destiny.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- So, I think they,
they know the beauty of
the world we came from,
but they also understand why we left.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
Well, that's important.
(audience applauds)
What impresses your kids the most?
Like, you taking risks in your life
or you knowing Kendall Jenner?
(Julia and audience laughs)
What is the big thing?
- Well, I think it's that, you know,
I left a world, you know I always say,
"I'm a time traveler".
I left the 1800's and I came to...
Because I mean, that's kind
of, the world I lived in.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Women got married, they
had babies when they were 19.
They're supposed to be,
you know, obedient to their husbands.
It was a very different kind of world.
And then, I came into this world,
without a college education,
without knowing anything
and then I started a shoe brand.
So, I think for them,
it's that time travel journey.
The fact that I, at 42 years old,
picked myself up and
started an entire new life.
- [Kelly] That's so cool.
- That, you know, I think that's the thing
that they appreciate the most.
- [Kelly] Yeah, absolutely.
- [Julia] Yeah.
- It was a joke, the Kendall thing.
(audience applauds)
(Julia laughs)
But speaking of, the
reason why I brought it up,
is because this is a shot of the gown
that you made her for the Met Gala.
So, I want to show,
this is a few years ago.
- [Lisa] Wow.
(audience gasps)
- [Kelly] Like, oh.
I mean, first of all, were we
supposed to look like that?
Like, I don't understand
what's happening there.
But like, I mean, that is beautiful
and how is that held together?
- Oh, my gosh.
- I feel like its delicate.
- Oh my God, no, you have no idea.
Literally, I had total nightmares,
because I wanted to make a
dress that had no fabric.
It's just thread and 85,000 crystals.
- Wow.
- What?
- And the problem though...
- I love that you wanted to
make a dress with no fabric.
I just have to stop there for a minute.
(Kelly laughs)
That was your idea.
I had a dream and...
- Wow.
- No fabric needed.
- Because you know, it's
about thinking out of the box.
- I love it, it's beautiful.
- So, my only fear is
you see how like, it on the bottom there,
it kind of falls on the ground.
I was petrified.
- [Kelly] Ooh, someone would step on it.
- [Julia] Yes.
- [Kelly] That's happened to me.
- [Julia] I mean, imagine,
because if you step on somebody's dress...
- [Kelly] And it rips.
- And it rips.
If someone stepped on her dress.
- [Kelly] Oh, no.
- 85,000 crystals would come crashing down
and she would be...
- In the buff.
Yeah, just as Eve was.
- [Julia] And so, that
was my literal panic.
- I wanted to have like,
security guards around her
so that no one would be able
to go anywhere near the dress.
- And people always step on your dress,
or maybe it's just me.
I feel like people always...
- [Lisa] They do.
- Yeah.
- They do.
- I know, anytime I see a
train, I'm like, "I am screwed".
(audience laughs)
Yeah, yeah.
They're going to, it's going to happen.
- And I was at the Met Gala.
- But Julia, it could
have been tea length.
- [Kelly] Tea length.
(Kelly laughs)
- [Julia] I always make
life difficult for myself.
This is what I do, I don't know.
- It was so beautiful, though.
- Thank you.
- I love that you thought
outside of the box.
- Thank you.
- I think that was really cool.
- It was really fun.
- So, the new book, so
this is called "Brazen".
- [Lisa] Oh, my gosh.
- I know, it's very fancy.
- Wow.
- So, it's an autobiography.
So, it's called "Brazen".
So, why did you want to write this?
Why did you feel like it was important?
- Well, you know, I've been
through quite an unusual journey
and even through the TV show,
people would say to me,
"Because I watched your
show, I left a bad marriage,
I started my business".
I had two people tell me this,
they had been planning to commit suicide.
- Oh, wow.
- And after they saw
the show, they didn't.
So to me, the book,
because this show was
about my current life,
informed by my past.
The book tells my whole, crazy journey.
And it's a mess.
And I'm very honest, because
I made a lot of mistakes,
because I didn't know any better.
- I think we all have, yeah.
- You know, but I want people to know
that the mistakes are
part of the journey too.
And that they shouldn't be
afraid to make mistakes,
they shouldn't be afraid
to try new things.
So, I'm hoping that this
book inspires people,
gives people the courage to...
- [Kelly] Helps people, yeah.
- Yeah, gives people the courage to get up
and demand what they want from life
and not be held down by
people or others telling you
that you cannot or society,
whatever it is that's holding you back.
I'm, really, I pray that
people read this book and say,
"Hey, if this crazy lady
can do it, so can I".
(Kelly laughs)
(audience applauds)
- I feel like it would be hard for us
to find anyone in life that
doesn't have a messy path.
We all have like, messes, you know?
- Of course.
- Yeah.
- And I was so clueless.
- It's if you wallow in it
or you pick it up and keep going.